Jake: 好然后一个秒表
Jake: Okay, then we need a stopwatch.
Shure:  时间戳呗
Shure: Mark a timestamp, right?
Jake: 对 戳一下
Jake: Yes, mark it.
Jake: 来都戳一下
Jake: Come on, everyone mark it.
Jake: 每人戳一下
Jake: Each person marks it.
Jake: 传过去戳一下哎
Jake: Pass it along and mark it, hey.
Jake: 你能看到对吗
Jake: You can see it, right?
Jake: 好戳完了
Jake: Alright, all done marking.
Jake: 行
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 开机开
Jake: Turn it on.
Jake:  就是今天我们就讨论讨论
Jake: So today we're just going to discuss a bit.
Jake: 早上讨论讨论
Jake: Discuss this morning.
Jake: 我们最后一天干点啥呗
Jake: What should we do on our last day?
Jake: 然后可能
Jake: And then maybe...
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm...
Jake: 就是这边还有4个
Jake: There are still 4 more here.
Jake: 这个USB就可能这
Jake: These USBs, maybe this...
Jake: 这叫什么
Jake: What's this called?
Jake: 这个硬盘
Jake: This hard drive.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm...
Jake: 早上我觉得大家主要是讨论
Jake: In the morning, I think everyone should mainly discuss.
Jake: 然后讨论的时候闲着没事
Jake: And while discussing, if we have nothing to do...
Jake: 如果大家陷入了沉思
Jake: If everyone gets lost in thought...
Jake: 陷入了尴尬
Jake: Or it gets awkward...
Jake: 可以把这个给装一装
Jake: We can install this.
Jake: 对只是一个back up
Jake: Yes, just as a backup.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm...
Jake: 所以
Jake: So...
Jake: 现在就尴尬了啊
Jake: Now it's awkward, huh?
Shure:  没有没有先看 拆开看是什么
Shure: No, no, let's open it up and see what it is first.
Jake: 行那也行那也行
Jake: Alright, that works too.
Jake: 哇哦
Jake: Wow.
Lucia: 只有4个吗
Lucia: Only 4 of them?
Jake: 对只有4个
Jake: Yes, only 4.
Lucia: 那要不没事没事
Lucia: That's okay.
Lucia: 我拆过这个
Lucia: I've taken this apart before.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake: 因为你是menter
Jake: Because you're the mentor.
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Ah, yes.
Jake: tutor
Jake: Tutor.
Lucia: 哈哈我已经装过这个东西了
Lucia: Haha, I've already installed this thing.
Shure:  需要充电宝在这里拿
Shure: If you need a power bank, take one from here.
Lucia: 好的谢谢
Lucia: Okay, thanks.
Jake: 我先把这些端走
Jake: I'll take these away first.
Katrina:  哇还有螺丝呀
Katrina: Wow, there are screws too!
Jake: 好 大家拆出来了可以摆成什么样呢
Jake: Okay, what can you make out of these once they're dismantled?
Jake: 摆成
Jake: Make it into...
Jake: 这个盒子要留着
Jake: Keep this box.
Jake: 嗯里边这个东西可以丢掉
Jake: Hmm, you can throw away what's inside.
Jake: 这东西都丢掉吧
Jake: Just throw all this stuff away.
Shure:  这眼镜布留着
Shure: Keep this lens cloth.
Jake:好那就先摆成这样
Jake: Okay, let's arrange it like this for now.
Jake: 这个是等大家陷入沉思的时候再用
Jake: We'll use this when everyone is deep in thought.
Jake: 但是这个我可以跟大家先讲一下
Jake: But I can explain it to everyone first.
Jake: 这个东西是什么呢
Jake: What is this thing?
Jake: 就大家可以看这个地方
Jake: So, you can see this place.
Jake: 你们也看不见这个地方
Jake: Actually, you can't see this place.
Jake: 或者你们过来吧
Jake: Or you guys can come over.
Jake: 走动走动
Jake: Walk around.
Jake: 就是看我的工作间
Jake: Just check out my workstation.
Shure:  我们这算私闯闺房吗
Shure: Are we trespassing into your private space?
Jake: 那请请请请
Jake: No, no, please come in.
Jake: 工作间
Jake: The workstation.
Jake: 然后这地方是一共有6台电脑对吧
Jake: And here, there are a total of six computers, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake: 然后这7台
Jake: And this is the seventh.
Jake: 8台
Jake: Eighth.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 9台 10台
Jake: Ninth, tenth.
Jake: 但是就是这边6台电脑
Jake: But mainly, six computers here.
Jake: 每一个电脑
Jake: Each computer.
Jake: 都对应着你们的一台眼镜
Jake: Corresponds to one of your glasses.
Jake: 然后这个每一台电脑
Jake: Then, each computer.
Jake: 你们每次录完结束
Jake: After each recording session.
Jake: 每隔三个小时
Jake: Every three hours.
Jake: 然后会在这导到这个硬盘里边
Jake: Will transfer the data to this hard drive.
Jake: 然后这个硬盘
Jake: Then this hard drive.
Jake: 就是你们一会要装的硬盘
Jake: Is the one you will install later.
Jake: 就是比方说这个这个L1这个L1这个L2
Jake: For example, this L1, this L1, and this L2.
Jake: 然后这个名字的名字都写在这了
Jake: The names are all written here.
Jake: 哈哈哈你们的数据都在这个里边
Jake: Hahaha, all your data is in here.
Shure:  这我们的第二生命
Shure: This is our second life.
Jake: 对你们的第二生命都在这个里边啊
Jake: Yes, your second life is all in here.
Jake: 比方说我这个L1
Jake: For example, this is my L1.
Jake: 对吧然后你们结束之后
Jake: Right, then after you finish...
Jake: 就是会把这个眼镜插到这个上面
Jake: You'll plug these glasses into this thing.
Jake: 然后同时
Jake: And at the same time...
Jake: 现在一直接着这个第一个硬盘
Jake: Now always connecting to this first hard drive.
Jake: 对然后这个硬盘它有两根线
Jake: Yes, then this hard drive has two cables.
Jake: 一个是一个是接电脑的
Jake: One is for connecting to the computer.
Jake: 一个是接电源的
Jake: One is for the power source.
Jake: 然后这个电源
Jake: And this power source...
Jake: 是为了让这个硬盘假装自己在电脑上
Jake: Is to make this hard drive pretend it's on a computer.
Jake: 所以这个盒的意思就是说
Jake: So the purpose of this box is to...
Jake: 他给模拟一个电脑的环境
Jake: Simulate a computer environment for it.
Jake: 然后用硬盘对对
Jake: Then use the hard drive, right.
Jake: 让硬盘能知道自己要工作了
Jake: So the hard drive knows it needs to work.
Jake: 对啊然后这个线啊
Jake: Yeah, and then this cable...
Jake: 这个线我们我们布线还挺有意思的
Jake: This cable, our cable management is pretty interesting.
Jake: 就长成这个样子
Jake: It looks like this.
Jake: 呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Shure: 是一个悬着的
Shure: It's kind of hanging.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Shure:  那如果突然停电了会怎么样
Shure: So what happens if there's a sudden power outage?
Jake: 那不好讲
Jake: That's hard to say.
Jake: 就是电脑突然停电
Jake: If the computer suddenly loses power...
Jake: 就是会很尴尬
Jake: It would be awkward.
Shure:  那没有什么
Shure: Then there's no...
Shure:  就是USP之类的
Shure: Like a USB backup power supply?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  就是那种备用电源
Shure: Like those backup power sources.
Jake: 哦哦没有
Jake: Oh, no.
Jake: 还没那么有钱
Jake: We're not that rich yet.
Jake: 我们只能相信这个别墅
Jake: We can only rely on this villa.
Jake: 或者相信北京电力吧
Jake: Or trust Beijing Electric.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Shure:  感谢
Shure: Thank you.
Jake: 好你们都开始装了
Jake: Alright, you guys start installing.
Shure:  我们我们可以
Shure: We, we can...
Jake: 可以边聊边装吧
Jake: You can chat while installing.
俢硕：对
Shure: Right.
Jake: 嗯或者说你们先带你们带点什么吧
Jake: Hmm, or you guys can bring something first.
Jake: 你们带点什么
Jake: What will you bring?
Jake: 哎这个这个眼镜你得带好
Jake: Hey, these glasses, you need to wear them properly.
Jake: 这眼镜
Jake: These glasses.
Jake: 嗯也不能遮住
Jake: Hmm, they shouldn't cover...
Jake: 应该都不没遮住吧
Jake: They shouldn't cover, right?
Jake: 你现在没遮住
Jake: You're not covering anything now.
Lucia: 但这里有一个孔
Lucia: But there's a hole here.
Lucia: 然后这个地方是要坐在这的
Lucia: And this part needs to sit here.
Lucia: 所以你要就是最好这样对齐
Lucia: So you need to align it like this.
Lucia: 然后慢慢往里推
Lucia: And then slowly push it in.
Lucia: 看怎么样能推进去
Lucia: See how it goes in.
Lucia: 好像要轻一点
Lucia: It seems like it needs to be gentle.
Lucia: 那天那同学跟我说这个挺脆弱的
Lucia: That day a classmate told me this is quite fragile.
Jake: 嗯对就是
Jake: Hmm, yeah, it is.
Shure:  没事搞定
Shure: No worries, got it.
Lucia: 就是这不是有一个口吗
Lucia: There's a notch here, right?
Lucia: 跟这个是对着的
Lucia: It aligns with this.
Lucia: 你就他们这样对着
Lucia: You just need to align them like this.
Lucia: 然后慢慢推
Lucia: 看这样说不定能把他推进去
俢硕：哎呦我天
Lucia: 要稍微使点力气
Lucia: 他这还是有一点紧的
Lucia: 但是别太使劲
Shure:  需要拧螺丝的地方吗没有吧
Lucia: 别掰坏了
Lucia: 好像很脆弱的样子，不过我其实也不是很懂这个
Jake: 有有有很多螺丝
Lucia: 要拧螺丝
Jake: 对
Shure: 那螺丝呢
Lucia: 在那里面
Shure:  哦懂了
Shure:  easy
Katrina:  然后就把它装进去了
Lucia: 嗯对然后要装到这个盒子里
Lucia: 就是你最好是把这个地方取下来
Lucia: 然后这个片就可以不要了
Lucia: 因为这里一会要也要用来拧螺丝
Lucia: Because we'll need to use this to screw in the bolts later.
Alice: 是不是只要拧4个螺丝
Alice: Do we just need to screw in 4 bolts?
Lucia: 呃8个
Lucia: Uh, 8.
Alice:8个吗
Alice: 8?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
俢硕：是的
Shure: That's right.
Lucia:  对你你把那个条抽出来
Lucia: Yes, you need to pull out that strip.
Lucia: 对然后就你看到那个孔了没
Lucia: Yes, and then, do you see that hole?
Lucia: 长条形那个
Lucia: The long one.
Lucia: 他那里面也有一个螺丝孔
Lucia: There's also a screw hole inside.
Lucia: 你要把那个也上上
Lucia: You need to screw that in too.
Lucia: 就是那个是大螺丝的螺丝孔
Lucia: That's the screw hole for the big screw.
Alice: 啊哪个
Alice: Ah, which one?
Lucia: 呃这里你看
Lucia: Uh, here, look.
Alice:我已经上上完一个螺丝
Alice: I've already screwed in one screw.
Lucia: 就是这个这个东西
Lucia: It's this one, this thing.
Lucia: 嗯我怎么样给你指的比较清楚
Lucia: Hmm, how can I point it out more clearly?
Lucia: 哎你上的这是对的
Lucia: Oh, you've got it right.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 对然后这边每个都有
Lucia: Yes, and each one over here has one.
Lucia: 然后这个也是所以一共是8个对的
Lucia: And this one too, so there are 8 in total.
Alice:昂
Alice: Got it.
Alice: 懂了看见了
Alice: I see it now.
Katrina:  这是大螺丝
Katrina: This is the big screw.
Alice: 没看见刚刚
Alice: I didn't see it earlier.
Katrina:  你看上在这儿是 吗
Katrina: See, it's here, right?
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Katrina: 小螺丝上这儿
Katrina: The small screw goes here.
Lucia: 对的
Lucia: Correct.
Alice: 哦里边是把它插进去就行了吧
Alice: Oh, inside, just insert it, right?
Alice: 就那个
Alice: Just that one.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Alice: 呃那个对
Alice: Uh, that one, right.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 里面应该插进去就就行了
Lucia: Inside, it should just be inserted, that's it.
Alice: 叫啥集成电路还是什么
Alice: What's it called, an integrated circuit or something?
Jake: 上一回我们一直在抱怨磁吸的问题
Jake: Last time, we kept complaining about the magnetic issue.
Jake: 但是好像今天大家都没有什么
Jake: But it seems like today, no one has any problems.
Lucia: 对今天大家好像接受良好
Lucia: Yes, today everyone seems to be okay with it.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Alice:什么实吸的
Alice: What are you talking about?
俢硕：他
Shure: He
Shure:  毕竟附赠的这个不可能给你什么
Shure: After all, this freebie can't really give you anything.
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: Exactly, exactly.
Lucia: 这个螺丝刀它没有磁性
Lucia: This screwdriver isn't magnetic.
俢硕：没有磁吸
Shure: No magnetic attraction.
Lucia: 对所以就是在
Lucia: Yeah, so when
Katrina: 这是装大的
Katrina: This one is for the bigger screws.
Lucia: 放螺丝的时候就很麻烦
Lucia: It's really troublesome when you're putting screws in.
Lucia: 对是这里是放大的
Lucia: Yeah, this one is for the bigger ones.
Katrina:  嗯大的能卡进去
Katrina: Yeah, the big one can fit in.
Lucia: 呃他就是这样子
Lucia: Um, it's just like this.
Lucia: 他没有办法就穿过这个孔
Lucia: It can't really go through this hole.
Lucia: 你就是要把
Lucia: You just have to
Jake: 你的头发总喜欢挡着镜头要不想想办法
Jake: Your hair is always blocking the camera, can you do something about it?
Tasha: 这个吗
Tasha: This one?
Jake: 对或者塞到里边去
Jake: Yeah, or tuck it inside.
Tasha: 我塞了已经
Tasha: I've already tucked it in.
Katrina: 找个小夹子
Katrina: Find a small clip.
Lucia: 应该只要把它固定住就好
Lucia: You just need to fix it in place.
Lucia:  是是这样吗
Lucia: Is this okay?
Jake: 嗯这个好
Jake: Yeah, this is good.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We
Shure:  是不是可以有一点BGM
Shure: Can we have some background music?
Jake:那你放一点
Jake: Then you can play some.
Lucia: 支持来
Lucia: Go ahead.
Shure:  大家平时爱听什么类型的音乐
Shure: What kind of music do you guys usually listen to?
Katrina:  我我听陶喆
Katrina: I listen to David Tao.
Jake: 陶喆类型的音乐
Jake: David Tao type of music.
Katrina:  嗯RMB
Katrina: Yeah, R&B.
Jake:  RMB
Jake: R&B.
Shure: R&B
Shure: R&B.
Lucia: 我是混欧美圈的
Lucia: I'm into Western music.
Lucia: 所以就乱听
Lucia: So I listen to random stuff.
Alice: 给大家一个比较干劲的
Alice: Let's play something energetic for everyone.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina:  那个东北雨姐的BGM
Katrina: How about some upbeat music from Northeast China?
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈ok
Shure: Hahaha, okay.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake:来自东方的小小震撼
Jake: A little shock from the East.
Alice:笑死我了贼有劲
Alice: I'm dying of laughter, it's so powerful.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 来
Shure: Come on.
Jake: 跳吧要不然
Jake: Jump then, or else...
Shure:  我想扛起来了
Shure: I want to lift it up.
Katrina: 扛起来
Katrina: Lift it up.
Shure:  这个半嵌入就行是吧
Shure: Just embed this halfway, right?
Shure:  这样
Shure: Like this.
Jake: 对对固定就行
Jake: Yeah, just fix it.
Alice: OK
Alice: OK.
Shure:  大东北我的家乡
Shure: My hometown in the Great Northeast.
Jake: 你东北哪的呀
Jake: Where in the Northeast are you from?
Shure:  我稻花香
Shure: I'm from Daohuaxiang.
Jake: 东北稻花的
Jake: From Northeast Daohua?
Shure:  不是不是
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  那个长春的
Shure: From Changchun.
Jake: 长春的
Jake: Changchun.
Shure:  吉林省长春市大家知道这个城市吗
Shure: Changchun, Jilin Province, does everyone know this city?
Katrina: 知道呀
Katrina: Yes.
Shure:  大家知道吉林省还有个吉林市吗
Shure: Does everyone know there's also a city named Jilin in Jilin Province?
Alice:昂
Alice: Uh-huh.
Jake: 啊对这也知道
Jake: Ah, yes, we know that too.
Jake: 怎么你在吉林市
Jake: So are you in Jilin City?
Shure:  没有我在长春
Shure: No, I'm in Changchun.
Jake: 你们隔壁是吧
Jake: Your neighbor, right?
Shure:  好像是
Shure: Seems like it.
Shure:  大东北
Shure: Great Northeast.
Shure:  AI人类为什么喜欢听这样的音乐
Shure: AI, why do humans like listening to this kind of music?
Jake:这个在后面
Jake: This goes in the back.
Katrina:  人类迷惑行为
Katrina: Human confusing behavior.
Jake: 然后这边有一个螺丝
Jake: Then there's a screw here.
Jake: 你看两边
Jake: Look at both sides.
Lucia: 外面这好像不装回去也
Lucia: It seems like we don't have to put this back.
Lucia: 也可以就这个条
Lucia: We can just use this strip.
Lucia: 我们那天反正好像都扔了我记得
Lucia: I remember we threw it away last time anyway.
Shure:  这条刚好
Shure: This strip fits perfectly.
Lucia: 这条可以扔
Lucia: We can throw this strip away.
Jake: 可以放可以放
Jake: We can put it here, we can put it here.
Jake: 我昨天成功的放了进去
Jake: I successfully put it in yesterday.
Lucia: 哦哦原来如此
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 那那那咱那天的嘞
Lucia: What about that day then?
Jake: 没关系对
Jake: It doesn't matter.
Jake: 它就是美观
Jake: It's just for aesthetics.
Jake: 它就是看的没有螺丝
Jake: It looks like there are no screws.
Alice:可以了吗
Alice: Is it done?
Jake: 然后把它这样
Jake: Then you do it like this.
Shure: 可以进场了
Shure: Ready to go in.
Lucia: 哈可以进场
Lucia: Oh, ready to go in.
Alice: 可以我已经进过场了
Alice: Yes, I’ve already been in.
Jake: 啊你你进过场玩过
Jake: Oh, you've been in and played?
Alice: 我觉得我们大学那些接线的
Alice: I think the wiring we did in college...
Alice: 焊板子的跟进场没啥区别
Alice: Soldering boards, it's no different from going in.
Jake: 互联网吗
Jake: Internet?
Jake: 还是什么
Jake: Or what?
Alice: 嗯对电工
Alice: Yeah, electrician.
Katrina:  电工嗯
Katrina: Electrician, yeah.
Katrina: 焊板子的
Katrina: Soldering boards.
Lucia: 哦对电工实习会做一些神奇的东西
Lucia: Oh right, electrician internships do some magical things.
Katrina: 我不知当时
Katrina: I didn't know back then...
Jake:对    最后
Jake: Right, in the end...
Lucia: 最后我们学校也是
Lucia: In the end, our school also...
Jake: 最后放成这个样子好吧然后就就可以出叫出场了对
Jake: Finally, put it like this, then it can be called done, right?
Katrina: 开玩笑我们阮工 也要训练
Katrina: Just kidding, our Nguyen engineer also needs training.
Jake: 出流水线
Jake: On the assembly line.
Jake: 下一个流水线
Jake: Next assembly line.
Lucia: 下一个流水线是让你接到电脑上的
Lucia: The next assembly line connects to the computer.
Jake:嘿嘿嘿
Jake: Hehehe.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure:  下一个需要高级技工
Shure: The next one needs a senior technician.
Lucia: 哈哈哈高级技工
Lucia: Hahaha, senior technician.
Alice:哈哈哈暂停
Alice: Hahaha, pause.
Alice:吵吵的
Alice: Noisy.
Jake: 3,000的技工到5,000的技工
Jake: From a 3,000 technician to a 5,000 technician.
Shure:  你说这是技工吗
Shure: You call this a technician?
Alice: 什么是技工
Alice: What's a technician?
Alice: 鸡公煲
Alice: Chicken pot.
Lucia: 技术工人 技术工人
Lucia: Skilled worker, skilled worker.
Shure:  哎为什么我
Shure: Hey, why me?
Alice: 因为你按反了啊
Alice: Because you pressed it the wrong way.
Jake:因为按反了
Jake: Because you pressed it the wrong way.
Shure: 昂啊
Shure: Oh, I see.
Jake: 这个是有俩螺丝
Jake: There are two screws here.
Shure: 哦哦哎哎
Shure: Oh, oh, right, right.
Jake: 你看侧面哎
Jake: Look at the side here.
Jake: 2,000 了是吧2,000了
Jake: 2,000, right? It’s 2,000.
Shure:  完了丢人了倒数第一个
Shure: Oh no, I’m the last one, how embarrassing.
Shure:   不行我必须要争一下
Shure: No, I have to fight for it.
Shure:  我不能倒数第一
Shure: I can't be the last one.
Jake: 哈哈好
Jake: Haha, okay.
Jake: 硬盘硬盘锦标赛
Jake: Hard drive competition.
Katrina: 你完了然后呢就不用干什么了吧
Katrina: You’re done, so you don’t need to do anything else, right?
Lucia: 拧完应该就就好了
Lucia: Tighten it, and it should be fine.
Jake:对 放那儿就行
Jake: Yes, just leave it there.
Shure:  他风轻云淡的说一句拧完了
Shure: He casually says he’s done tightening it.
Shure:  然后呢
Shure: Then what?
Shure:  他挑衅我
Shure: He’s provoking me.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn.
Jake:到底还有机会吗
Jake: Do we still have a chance?
Katrina:  是这样吗
Katrina: Is it like this?
Lucia: 应该是吧
Lucia: It should be, right?
Jake: 对对对放到这个盒子里面
Jake: Yes, yes, put it in this box.
Shure:  你看你没有装上那一关
Shure: Look, you didn’t put it in that level.
Jake: 这出场对这就是最后一步
Jake: This is the entrance, yes, this is the last step.
Lucia:条壮壮的都行不装了挺麻烦的
Lucia: It’s fine if you don’t install it, it’s quite troublesome.
Jake: 给你一点机会但是你还是没有抓住
Jake: I gave you a chance, but you still missed it.
Lucia: 你可以把条放在里面
Lucia: You can put the strip inside.
Lucia: 如果需要装的话
Lucia: If it needs to be installed.
Lucia: 然后尽量自己装就好了
Lucia: Then try to install it yourself.
Jake: 没需要装完全没必要放里面就好
Jake: No need to install, just put it inside, it’s fine.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Shure:  大家可以出场了
Shure: Everyone can go out now.
Jake: 出场好谢谢大家
Jake: Exit, thank you everyone.
Jake: 完成了一个奇怪的第一次任务
Jake: Completed a strange first task.
Jake: 然后这个EGO life最后一天
Jake: And this is the last day of EGO life.
Jake: 大家会邀请什么人呢
Jake: Who will you invite?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure:  最后一天
Shure: The last day
Jake: 最后一天
Jake: The last day
Shure: 是周日是吗
Shure: It's Sunday, right?
Jake: 周周日周日下午吧
Jake: Sunday afternoon, maybe
Shure:  啊咱俩会邀请什么人
Shure: Who are we inviting?
Jake: 会邀请几个人
Jake: We'll invite a few people.
Jake: 呀
Jake: Yeah
Shure:  黑板写一写吧
Shure: Let's write it on the blackboard.
Katrina: 应该一个吧
Katrina: Should be one, right?
Jake: 对黑板可以写一写
Jake: Yeah, we can write it on the blackboard.
Shure:  来我来我字非常好看
Shure: Let me do it, I have great handwriting.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Sure
Jake: 我们还有一个架子
Jake: We also have a shelf
Jake: 要不我们也拼一下好
Jake: Why don't we assemble it too?
Shure:  什么架子
Shure: What shelf?
Jake: 就是就是
Jake: Just, just
Jake: 你如果觉得这个这么写很难写的话
Jake: If you find writing this way difficult
Jake: 它其实有一个
Jake: There's actually a
Jake: 就这个东西就是你可以下这些
Jake: This thing, you can put these down
Shure: 等等再装吧先写吧
Shure: Let's assemble it later, let's write first.
Jake: 这问题不大是吧
Jake: It's not a big problem, right?
Shure:  问题不大问题不大
Shure: Not a big problem, not a big problem.
Jake:问题不大
Jake: Not a big problem.
Shure:  不影响我这个书法的发挥
Shure: It won't affect my calligraphy.
Jake: 笔呢
Jake: Where's the pen?
Shure: 笔呢
Shure: Where's the pen?
Shure: 好问题
Shure: Good question.
Jake: 好问题
Jake: Good question.
Shure:  问问他问问AI笔呢
Shure: Ask him, ask AI, where's the pen?
Jake: 笔呢笔呢
Jake: Where's the pen, where's the pen?
Lucia: 寻找我的iPhone吗
Lucia: Looking for my iPhone?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:对笔呢
Jake: Yeah, where's the pen?
Lucia: 寻找我的
Lucia: Looking for my...
Lucia: 寻找我的pencil
Lucia: Looking for my pencil.
Jake: 笔应该在上面
Jake: The pen should be up there.
Jake: 等一下啊
Jake: Hold on.
Lucia: 哎所以我们的E人到底是哪两位啊
Lucia: Hey, so who exactly are our guests?
Jake: 笔
Katrina: 我
Katrina: Me
Shure:  我也是E
Shure: Me too, I'm a...
Lucia: 哎你 是一吗
Lucia: Hey, are you an "I"?
Shure:   我我是e不是一啊OK
Shure: No, I'm an "E", not "I", OK?
Jake:  有啥差别啊
Jake: What's the difference?
Jake: 嗯你是一
Jake: Hmm, you're an "I"?
Lucia: 所以哎等等我们是三三三e两i
Lucia: So, wait a minute, we are three "E"s, two "I"s.
Katrina:  他要是一就完蛋了
Katrina: If he was an "I", we'd be doomed.
Shure: 我是
Shure: I'm...
Lucia: 哎那咱俩是然后呢
Lucia: Hey, so we are... and then?
Lucia: 啊OK昨天我没有
Lucia: Ah, OK, yesterday I didn't...
Shure: 我们来辩一下
Shure: Let's debate a bit.
Lucia: 昨天我没有猜出来
Lucia: Yesterday I didn't guess it.
Lucia: 虽然我猜到他可能是疑人
Lucia: Although I thought he might be a suspect.
Shure: EGO life
Shure: EGO life.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  最后一天的名单
Shure: The final day's list.
Jake:行啊
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  你
Shure: You...
Shure: 要
Shure: Need...
Jake:哈哈可以
Jake: Haha, sure.
Jake:是这么写的
Jake: This is how it's written.
Jake: 笔画
Jake: Strokes.
Shure: 11是这么写的
Shure: Yeah, this is how 11 is written.
Jake: 是这么写的
Jake: This is how it's written.
Shure:  夹子的夹怎么写呵呵呵
Shure: How do you write "夹"? Haha.
Shure: 啊太久没写
Shure: Ah, it's been too long since I wrote it.
Alice: 宝盖头
Alice: It starts with "宝".
Tasha: 宝盖头宝盖
Tasha: "宝", "宝".
Jake:哼哼呵呵呵
Jake: Hmm, hmm, haha.
Shure:  OK第一位
Shure: OK, the first one.
Jake: 修硕你邀请几个人啊
Jake: Shure, how many people did you invite?
Shure:  我浅浅邀一个吧先
Shure: I'll start by inviting just one.
Jake: 浅浅先邀一个啊
Jake: Just one to start?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Jake: 路亚呢
Jake: What about Luya?
Lucia: 我不太确定因为咱们这太远了
Lucia: I'm not sure because it's too far.
Lucia: 我不知道我小伙伴过不过得来
Lucia: I don't know if my friend can make it.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 好那你的工作室
Jake: Okay, then your studio...
Tasha: 我浅浅邀请一个吧
Tasha: I'll just invite one for now.
Jake: 好浅浅邀请一个
Jake: Okay, Tasha, invite someone.
Shure:  叫什么名字
Shure: What's their name?
Jake: 用不着这就用不着了
Jake: No need, there's no need.
Jake: 就是大概画个正字得了
Jake: Just roughly draw a tick mark.
Shure:  啊画正字好
Shure: Ah, a tick mark, got it.
Jake: 或者你用那个小球
Jake: Or you can use that little ball.
Jake: 我估计也够
Jake: I think that's enough.
Katrina:  画小人吧
Katrina: Draw a little person.
Katrina:  男生就是这样
Katrina: Boys are like this.
Katrina:  女生夹两边
Katrina: Girls are on both sides.
Shure:  你邀请
Shure: You invite.
Jake:额呵呵呵
Jake: Uh, hehe.
Tasha: 这是你邀请的女生吗
Tasha: Is this the girl you invited?
Shure:  啊你啊
Shure: Ah, you?
Tasha: 那我也邀请一位女生
Tasha: Then I'll invite a girl too.
Lucia: 你这个你这个辫
Lucia: This, this braid.
Lucia: 他这个接口没有在头上这个
Lucia: This connection isn't on top of the head.
Alice:抽象
Alice: Abstract.
Katrina:  假发
Katrina: Wig.
Alice:我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Shure:  哈哈我们重填一下哎
Shure: Haha, let's redo it.
Jake:哼哼奥特曼
Jake: Hmm, Ultraman.
Katrina:  我应该邀请一个男生
Katrina: I should invite a boy.
Shure:  男生
Shure: A boy.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice: 爱心童的
Alice: Loving children.
Katrina: 三条腿
Katrina: Three legs.
Jake: 这合适吧这样
Jake: Is this okay like this?
Shure:  对不起不小心画出头
Shure: Sorry, I accidentally drew the head.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Lucia: 我其实可以问一个女生但我不确定他能不能过得来
Lucia: I could actually ask a girl, but I'm not sure if she can make it.
Lucia: 因为他那边挺远的
Lucia: Because she's quite far.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈存疑是吧存疑
Lucia: Hahaha, doubtful, right? Doubtful.
Shure: ok存疑
Shure: OK, doubtful.
Shure: 还有呢
Shure: Anything else?
Alice:额我可以
Alice: Uh, I can.
Jake:  你可以在每个人下面写一个名字
Jake: You can write a name under everyone.
Jake: 写一个他的host
Jake: Write their host.
Shure:  host是吗
Shure: Host, right?
Jake: 嗯就是你的代号吧之类
Jake: Yeah, like your code name or something.
Shure:  认领一下
Shure: Claim it
Jake: 不不不
Jake: No no no
Jake: 你就在这个小人的下面写一个
Jake: Just write one under this little guy
Jake: 或者在上面或者脸上写一个之类的
Jake: Or write one above or on the face or something
Shure:  这是谁的来着
Shure: Whose is this again?
Alice:额塔莎
Alice: Uh, Tasha's
Shure: 昂塔莎
Shure: Oh, Tasha's
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then
Alice:这个是你喜欢的
Alice: This is the one you like
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Katrina: 那就写LYX
Katrina: Then just write LYX
Katrina: LYX
Jake: 啊哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ah hahaha
Shure:  这这位是谁的人
Shure: Whose person is this?
Shure:  我录像或者写个l也行哈哈哈
Shure: I record it or write an L, that's fine haha
Shure: NC艾特
Shure: NC @
Shure:  还有呢你要邀请奖了是吗
Shure: Also, are you going to invite the award?
Alice: 对但是有一个可能来不了
Alice: Yeah, but one might not come
Shure:  性别
Shure: Gender
Alice:都是女的呵
Alice: All girls, heh
Shure: 呵
Shure: Heh
Alice: 有一个不知道能来不能
Alice: There's one who might not be able to come
Alice: 你给我画个星就行了五角星
Alice: Just draw me a star, a five-pointed star
Alice:;OK了
Alice: OK
Shure:  OK
Shure:  现在我们有一二三四五六六位嘉宾
Shure: Now we have one, two, three, four, five, six, six guests
Jake: 嗯呃4-6位嘉宾
Jake: Hmm, uh, 4-6 guests
Shure:  对 4-6位
Shure: Yeah, 4-6 guests
Jake:4-6位嘉宾OK
Jake: 4-6 guests, OK
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh
Jake: 我们原来还打算有可能的话
Jake: We originally planned, if possible
Jake: 去邀请周围的人
Jake: To invite people from around here
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah
Jake: 就是或者小红书
Jake: Like from Xiaohongshu
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or
Lucia: 是采取挨家挨户敲门询问的方式吗
Lucia: Is it like going door to door asking?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh
Jake: 环球影城门口直接抓人
Jake: Grabbing people directly at Universal Studios
Tasha: 提一篮子 鸡蛋比较好
Tasha: Bringing a basket of eggs is better
Lucia: 提一篮确实如果
Lucia: Carrying a basket, indeed, if...
Lucia: 如果就是如果他们来的话可以发鸡蛋
Lucia: If they come, we can give them eggs.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure:  明天咱们这地就被举报了
Shure: Tomorrow, we'll get reported here.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake: 明天可以拍一段警察的镜头
Jake: Tomorrow, we can shoot a scene with the police.
Shure: 二 邀请邻居
Shure: Second, invite the neighbors.
Shure:  哎这邀字好难写
Shure: Oh, this "invite" character is hard to write.
Jake: 要不隐外字吧
Jake: How about using a simpler character?
Shure:  我觉得也是
Shure: I think so too.
Tasha: 带上鸡蛋
Tasha: Bring the eggs.
Tasha: 你要是来我就把这一篮送你
Tasha: If you come, I'll give you this basket.
Tasha: 你不来就不送
Tasha: If you don't come, no eggs for you.
Shure:  邻居
Shure: Neighbors.
Shure:  哎这字
Shure: Oh, this character...
Shure:  齐白石看着都落泪
Shure: Even Qi Baishi would cry looking at it.
Alice: 有种复古的感觉
Alice: It has a vintage feel.
Shure:  这是我们的plan
Shure: This is our plan.
Shure:  存疑plan
Shure: Suspicious plan.
Shure:  ok
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 好多问号啊
Lucia: So many question marks.
Lucia: 我们好像谜语人
Lucia: We look like riddlers.
Shure:  riddle
Shure: Riddle.
Shure:  然后我们还还有
Shure: And we still have...
Shure:  还有什么
Shure: What else?
Shure:  呃这是人员
Shure: Uh, this is the personnel.
Shure:  部分
Shure: Section.
Jake: 剧组吧剧组还有5个人
Jake: The crew, we still have 5 people.
Jake: 然后就是总共看
Jake: Then let's see overall...
Jake: 最后我们要host多少个人
Jake: Finally, how many people do we have to host?
Jake: 然后看看这活动在这个人数下
Jake: And see what we should do with this number.
Jake: 应该整点啥
Jake: What should we do?
Alice: 屌丝
Alice: Loser.
Jake: 给大家拍
Jake: And filmed it for everyone.
Lucia: 这是不是可以技术处理一下吗
Lucia: Can't we handle this technically?
Jake: 是但是后期很麻烦
Jake: Yes, but it's a hassle in post-production.
Shure: 后期给
Shure: It's a hassle in post-production.
Shure:  添了多少麻烦
Shure: How much trouble for post-production.
Shure:  OK所以总共one two three four
Shure: OK, so in total, one, two, three, four...
Alice: 4到6
Alice: 4 to 6.
Shure:   four加五五个这是9
Shure: Four plus five, that makes nine.
Jake: 四加五 九九到11是吧
Jake: Four plus five, nine. Nine to eleven, right?
Shure:  9到11 人
Shure: Nine to eleven people.
Jake: 9到11 然后各位自己
Jake: Nine to eleven, then everyone will...
Shure:  算算上我们是吧
Shure: Count us in, right?
Jake: 哎就先先先谢谢9-11吧
Jake: Yeah, let's start with nine to eleven.
Jake: 9-11
Jake: Nine to eleven.
Shure:  9-11 正无穷
Shure:  因为我们可以邀请邻居
Shure: Because we can invite the neighbors.
Jake: 嗯对对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Shure: 非常严谨吧
Shure: Very thorough, right?
Jake: 我们有无穷的邻居
Jake: We have endless neighbors.
Jake: 也不是正无穷吧 16亿
Jake: Maybe not endless, 1.6 billion.
Shure:  现在我们我我国人口有16亿了吗
Shure: Do we have 1.6 billion people now?
Jake: 14 那就14
Jake: Fourteen, let's say fourteen.
Shure: 14吧
Shure: Fourteen, then.
Shure:  完了这移动的五十万
Shure: Plus the five hundred thousand that move around.
Jake:爆爆多了这
Jake: That's a lot.
Jake: 合适吗
Jake: Is it appropriate?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 问题不大问题不大
Jake: No big deal, no big deal.
Shure:  第一点OK
Shure: First point, OK.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Shure:  然后好人员确定了
Shure: Then, the personnel is confirmed.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Shure:  嗯这是第一
Shure: Yeah, that's the first.
Shure:  第一大点的第三
Shure: The first big point's third.
Shure:  下面三个小点人员
Shure: Next, three sub-points about personnel.
Shure:  然后我们还有第二点
Shure: And then we have the second point.
Shure:  要开始
Shure: To start.
Shure:  活动内容部分吗
Shure: The activity content part?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  这我觉得是一块硬骨头我们要啃很久
Shure: I think this is a tough one, we're going to chew on this for a while.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Shure:  所以我们要直接先来这个吗
Shure: So should we start with this directly?
Jake: 那还有别的吗
Jake: Is there anything else?
Shure:  活动内容
Shure: Activity content.
Shure:  大家想想
Shure: Everyone, think about it.
Shure:  我记得大家问卷的时候应该是填过的
Shure: I remember everyone filled out the questionnaire, right?
Shure:   是吧
Shure: Right?
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  大家问卷填的是什么来着
Shure: What did everyone write in the questionnaire?
Shure:  不会都是GPT生成的吧
Shure: It wasn't all generated by GPT, was it?
Katrina:  不是哈哈哈我自己写的
Katrina: No, haha, I wrote it myself.
Jake: 湖南GPT生成的
Jake: Generated by Hunan GPT.
Shure:  那既然提到湖南GPT那我们先从
Shure:  Lyx同学哈哈哈
Shure: Lyx, haha.
Jake:完完了你完了你
Jake: Oh no, you're in trouble.
Katrina:  我我想是那个就是呃7天
Katrina: I, I was thinking, um, 7 days.
Katrina:  然后每我买那花嘛
Katrina: And then I bought flowers.
Katrina:  然后每人一个花瓶
Katrina: And everyone got a vase.
Katrina:  然后就相当于醒花一一到2天
Katrina: So the flowers would bloom in 1 to 2 days.
Katrina:  然后刚好他一个周期
Katrina: And it perfectly fits the cycle.
Katrina:  就是可以让这花慢慢的开放
Katrina: So the flowers would slowly bloom.
Katrina:  然后把这个花的花瓣
Katrina: Then I would use the petals.
Katrina:  然后做成那种压花
Katrina: To make pressed flowers.
Katrina:  然后就比较环保做成那种明信片
Katrina: It's more eco-friendly and can be made into postcards.
Katrina:  还有买了那种亚克力的玻璃
Katrina: I also bought some acrylic glass.
Katrina:  然后就嵌进去
Katrina: And embedded it in.
Katrina:  就是那种比较好看的手工
Katrina: It's a nice handmade craft.
Katrina:  然后也跟植物有关
Katrina: And it's related to plants.
Katrina:  然后原材料又是自己精心养了7天的
Katrina: The raw materials are carefully cultivated for 7 days.
Katrina:  然后又觉得形成了一个闭环
Katrina: So it forms a complete cycle.
Katrina:  就做了一些周边
Katrina: I made some peripherals.
Jake: 好上上才艺
Jake: Good, show your talent.
Katrina:  到时候那一天就可以分发给大家
Katrina: On that day, we can distribute them to everyone.
Katrina:  那花的在哪
Katrina: Where are the flowers?
Alice:在那儿
Alice: Over there.
Katrina:  花还要醒一的
Katrina: The flowers need to wake up.
Katrina:  因为我看我
Katrina: Because I saw...
Katrina:  我刚才想的是种那种什么东西
Katrina: I was thinking of planting something.
Katrina:  符合那种地球世界
Katrina: That fits the Earth Day theme.
Katrina:  地球日他7天基本上发不了芽
Katrina: But it wouldn't sprout in 7 days.
Katrina:  然后我就想是买这种花
Katrina: So I thought of buying these flowers.
Jake: 上才艺
Jake: Show your talent.
Katrina:  直接那个顺丰发过来云南的花
Katrina: Directly shipped by SF Express, flowers from Yunnan.
Jake:是这个吗
Jake: Is it this one?
Katrina:  是他好像有两个包
Katrina: It seems like he has two packages.
Katrina:  对我买了芍药啊什么的
Katrina: Yeah, I bought some peonies and stuff.
Shure: 天呐不想送了
Shure: Oh my god, I don't want to give them anymore.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  刚好一些花骨朵就这两天就可以开了
Katrina: Just right, some flower buds can bloom in the next couple of days.
Lucia: 你要找个剪刀什么的吗
Lucia: Do you need to find some scissors or something?
Alice: 剪刀
Alice: Scissors.
Katrina:  直接开始干吗还是说要把后面的列完
Katrina: Should we start directly or list everything first?
Jake: 呃先秀一下吧就是先秀一下
Jake: Uh, let's showcase a bit first, just showcase a bit.
Shure: 先秀一下
Shure: Let's showcase a bit first.
Alice: 剪刀在哪
Alice: Where are the scissors?
Katrina:  我买了好几束来着
Katrina: I bought quite a few bunches.
Shure:  剪刀在这呢
Shure: The scissors are here.
Katrina:  还买康乃馨
Katrina: And I also bought some carnations.
Jake: 眼神好啊小伙
Jake: Good eyes, young man.
Katrina:  剪刚好我们女孩子比较多哈哈
Katrina: Just cut them, we have more girls here, haha.
Katrina:  啊这也是
Katrina: Ah, that's true.
Katrina:  这花瓣就可以做压花
Katrina: These petals can be used for pressed flowers.
Katrina:  然后买了压花器还有那种干燥剂
Katrina: And then I bought a flower press and some desiccants.
Katrina:  这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Katrina:  这是花这个要酝酿一下
Katrina: These flowers need to be prepared a bit.
Alice: 是芍药吗
Alice: Are these peonies?
Katrina:  嗯我买多了我才知道
Katrina: Yeah, I only found out after I bought too many.
Katrina:  他说要一到两天才能开花
Katrina: He said it would take one to two days for them to bloom.
Katrina:  然后想时间就差不多
Katrina: So I thought the timing would be just right.
Katrina:  压花就要压两三天
Katrina: Pressed flowers need two to three days.
Katrina:  然后这个养个两三天
Katrina: And these need to be cared for two to three days.
Katrina:  这是什么百合
Katrina: What are these, lilies?
Alice:这是香雪兰还是啥铃兰百合蓝
Alice: Are these freesia or something? Lily of the valley, maybe?
Katrina:  什么百合来着
Katrina: What kind of lilies are these?
Tasha: 营养剂泡在水里面加速醒发的
Tasha: Nutrients soaked in water to speed up the blooming.
Alice: 这两个颜色的
Alice: These are the two colors.
Katrina:  对一个白一个黄
Katrina: Yeah, one white and one yellow.
Katrina:  是一个包裹
Katrina: It's one package.
Katrina:  我看我记得他好像发两个包裹
Katrina: I think I remember him sending two packages.
Jake: 要不他上我们也上
Jake: If he goes, we should go too.
Jake: 才艺你看看哪些是你的
Jake: Talents, see which ones are yours.
Tasha: 没有我的
Tasha: None of mine.
Jake: 没有你的啊
Jake: None of yours, huh?
Jake: 你没有买这个
Jake: You didn't buy this.
Jake: 外面的快递就只有雨轩的是吧
Jake: The only package outside is Yuxuan's, right?
Jake: 还有别人买快递的没
Jake: Did anyone else order a package?
Katrina:  你们买东西了吗
Katrina: Did you guys buy anything?
Shure:  还没呢
Shure: Not yet.
Lucia: 还没
Lucia: Not yet.
Jake: 行没问题
Jake: Okay, no problem.
Jake: 他仨都是自带的是吧
Jake: All three of them brought their own stuff, right?
Shure:  带资进组
Shure: They brought funding.
Shure:  你看这就有觉悟
Shure: You see, they've got the right mindset.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina:  然后呢
Katrina: And then?
Jake: 然后就比划比划比划比划
Jake: And then just gesture, gesture, gesture.
Katrina: 花瓶
Katrina: Vase.
Alice:先洗
Alice: Wash first.
Jake: 就是大概要个什么形式
Jake: So what kind of format are we looking at?
Katrina:  形式吗形式就是我们6个人一人一个
Katrina: Format, well, the six of us each get one.
Katrina:  花瓶我也买好了
Katrina: I already bought the vases.
Katrina:  然后大家把这花分分分分了以后养了
Katrina: Then everyone can distribute the flowers and take care of them.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  一一一到两三天
Katrina: In about one to two or three days,
Katrina:  呃他这个就会慢慢全部开了吗
Katrina: They'll slowly start to bloom.
Katrina:  开了以后就用这种花瓣或者是
Katrina: Once they bloom, we can use the petals or
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  我看他们压花
Katrina: I saw people pressing flowers.
Katrina:  就是直接把这个花骨朵花剪下来
Katrina: They just cut off the flower buds and press them.
Katrina:  然后就直接这样压
Katrina: Press them flat.
Katrina:  他就会变成一个那种平面的
Katrina: And they turn into a flat, spread-out flower.
Katrina:  然后展开的那个花
Katrina: Then we can put them on postcards.
Katrina:  然后就可以坐在那种明信片
Katrina: I bought those postcards and greeting cards.
Katrina:  我买的那种明信片贺卡
Katrina: And also, what are they called,
Katrina:  还有那个包括那个叫什么
Katrina: Those acrylic double-layer glass frames.
Katrina:  那种亚克力双层玻璃
Katrina: Like a frame, we can give them as gifts.
Katrina:  然后像像一个那种相框就可以
Katrina: And some leaves and stuff.
Katrina:  送给别人然后一些叶子啊什么的
Katrina: Then we can arrange them into a picture.
Katrina:  然后当时想的是
Katrina: I was thinking,
Katrina:  你不是有那个户外活动吗
Katrina: You have that outdoor activity, right?
Katrina:  我们就可以去捡一些叶子
Katrina: We can collect some leaves.
Jake:嗯嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Katrina:  然后就把它拼成一幅画一样的
Katrina: Then arrange them into a picture.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Right.
Katrina:  然后书签也有然后就大家自己做着玩
Katrina: And then there are bookmarks, so everyone can make their own for fun.
Katrina:  然后最后一天
Katrina: Then on the last day
Katrina:  因为想这种形式
Katrina: Because we wanted this format
Katrina:  这种就邀请什么各种好朋友啊什么的
Katrina: We invited all kinds of good friends and such.
Katrina:  就可以你自己做的自己养的
Katrina: You can make and raise your own.
Katrina:  然后分发给大家就挺好
Katrina: And then distribute them to everyone, it’s pretty nice.
Katrina:  然后也比较符合7天这个周期嘛
Katrina: It also fits well with the 7-day cycle.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 嗯要不先给他醒了吧
Alice: Hmm, why don't we wake him up first?
Katrina:  嗯可以啊今天我肯今天是一定要他醒
Katrina: Hmm, sure. Today I definitely want him to wake up.
Jake: 你们先聊吧这个回头下一个
Jake: You guys chat first, we’ll do the next one later.
Katrina: 行
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina:  下一个下一个谁
Katrina: Who’s next?
Alice:下一个
Alice: Next one.
Katrina: 我来弄这个吧
Katrina: I’ll handle this one.
Katrina:  哎呀一把菜叶 下一个谁来
Katrina: Ah, a bunch of veggie leaves. Who’s next?
Shure:  下一个露露亚同学
Shure: Next is Lucia.
Lucia: 昂我来
Lucia: Okay, I’ll go.
Shure: 露西
Shure: Lucia.
Lucia: 其实就是我的构思
Lucia: Actually, my idea
Lucia: 也跟DIY是有关系的
Lucia: Is also related to DIY.
Lucia: 对我刚我刚开始想的是
Lucia: At first, I was thinking
Lucia: 就是可以因为是世界地球日
Lucia: Since it’s Earth Day,
Lucia: 所以我想就是做一点环保一点的东西
Lucia: So I wanted to make something eco-friendly.
Lucia: 就我不知道大家有没有做过水母灯
Lucia: I don’t know if you guys have made jellyfish lamps before.
Lucia: 就这两年在景区还挺火的
Lucia: They’ve been pretty popular in scenic spots these past couple of years.
Lucia: 呃就是长得像水母一样的一个小灯
Lucia: It’s a little lamp that looks like a jellyfish.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 然后这个东西它原本是有材料包的
Lucia: And this thing originally comes with a materials kit.
Lucia: 就是可以直接在网上买材料包做
Lucia: You can buy the kit online and make it.
Lucia: 但是我就是我想的是
Lucia: But what I was thinking
Lucia: 就是既然是世界地球日的话
Lucia: Since it’s Earth Day,
Lucia: 我之前在网上刷到过一个教程
Lucia: I saw a tutorial online before.
Lucia: 就是可以用那个奶茶杯盖
Lucia: You can use a bubble tea cup lid
Lucia: 然后以它作为一个主体
Lucia: As the main part
Lucia: 然后就是再加一些丝带
Lucia: And then add some ribbons
Lucia: 或者串珠之类的
Lucia: Or beads and such.
Lucia: 呃我不知道咱们这有没有热热胶枪
Lucia: I don't know if we have a hot glue gun here.
Lucia: 如果没有的话
Lucia: If we don’t,
Lucia: 可以后面看有没有什么替代的
Lucia: We can see if there are any alternatives.
Lucia: 或者说买一个也行
Lucia: Or we could just buy one.
Lucia: 然后就是大家一起
Lucia: And then everyone together.
Lucia: 就是每个人都做一个这样的小灯
Lucia: Each person makes one of these little lights.
Lucia: 就是它还挺好看的
Lucia: They look pretty nice.
Lucia: 然后这是其中一个设想
Lucia: And that's one of the ideas.
Lucia: 还有一个就是也是
Lucia: Another idea is also...
Lucia: 有点这种怎么说呢
Lucia: How should I put it...
Lucia: 低碳和循环利用的
Lucia: It's low-carbon and recyclable.
Lucia: 就是大家有没有做过纸箱小狗
Lucia: Have you all ever made a cardboard dog?
Lucia: 就前段时间特别火那个啊
Lucia: It was really popular some time ago.
Katrina:  可以放在那个
Katrina: You can put it...
Lucia: 对然后可以放在门口
Lucia: Yes, you can put it at the door.
Katrina: 门口
Katrina: At the door.
Lucia: 然后纸箱小狗的好处就是
Lucia: And the good thing about the cardboard dog is...
Lucia: 如果想要很简单做一下的话
Lucia: If you want to make it simple...
Lucia: 就拿纸箱简单剪一下
Lucia: Just cut the cardboard simply.
Lucia: 然后画一个小狗头粘上就可以
Lucia: Then draw a dog head and stick it on.
Lucia: 如果想要复杂一点的话
Lucia: If you want it more complex...
Lucia: 就是也有一些
Lucia: There are also some...
Lucia: 就是复杂点就需要多剪几个
Lucia: For more complex ones, you need to cut more pieces.
Lucia: 然后做成一个大的
Lucia: And make a bigger one.
Lucia: 我之前看到有人做过杜宾
Lucia: I saw someone make a Doberman before.
Lucia: 但是那个我没做过就是
Lucia: But I haven't made that one myself.
Lucia: 但是就是看了一下教程
Lucia: I just watched the tutorial.
Lucia: 好像也挺简单的
Lucia: It seemed pretty easy.
Lucia: 只要画一下卡纸就能很容易剪出来
Lucia: Just draw on the cardboard and cut it out easily.
Shure:  咱们最不缺的就是纸箱
Shure: What we have plenty of is cardboard.
Shure:  所以我觉得这个
Shure: So I think this...
Lucia: 对我当时想的也是
Lucia: Yes, I was thinking the same.
Jake:对这个合理对
Jake: Yes, this makes sense.
Lucia: 在咱们这里到时候肯定会有很多纸箱
Lucia: We'll definitely have a lot of cardboard here.
Lucia: 如果说就能直接使用的话
Lucia: If we can directly use it...
Shure: 非常可行
Shure: It's very doable.
Lucia: 就还挺环保的
Lucia: It's quite environmentally friendly.
Lucia: 就也很契合世界地球日这个主题
Lucia: It fits the Earth Day theme well.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 然后最后还有一个想法
Lucia: And then there's one last idea.
Lucia: 但是这个想法实施起来就比较困难
Lucia: But this one is harder to implement.
Lucia: 我本来想的是
Lucia: I was thinking...
Lucia: 可能大家可以简单的排一个小短剧
Lucia: Maybe everyone could act out a short play.
Lucia: 或者之类的
Lucia: Or something like that.
Lucia: 对因为我之前跟我小伙伴有说
Lucia: Yeah, because I mentioned it to my buddy before.
Lucia: 我们今天拍一些微电影这种
Lucia: We are shooting some short films today.
Jake:买了
Jake: Bought it.
Lucia: 但是如果要拍一个小短剧的话
Lucia: But if we want to shoot a short skit,
Lucia: 就是我现在暂时还没有想到一个现成
Lucia: I haven't thought of a ready-made script yet.
Lucia: 我们目前就拿来用的剧本
Lucia: We don't have a script ready for now.
Lucia: 因为咱们时间比较短
Lucia: Because we are short on time.
Lucia: 就如果要现在去编的话
Lucia: If we were to write one now,
Lucia: 可能就不太来得及
Lucia: it might not be in time.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 就如果大家有想到什么
Lucia: So if anyone has any ideas,
Lucia: 你们以前看到过的短视频之类的
Lucia: like short videos you've seen before,
Lucia: 这种也可以
Lucia: those could work too.
Lucia: 就如果有个现成的剧本
Lucia: If there's a ready-made script,
Lucia: 我觉得咱们可以尝试拍一下对
Lucia: I think we can try to shoot it.
Shure:  OK好
Shure: OK, sounds good.
Lucia: 这个是目前暂时的想法
Lucia: This is the current idea for now.
Shure:  这是露西
Shure: This is Lucia.
Shure:  这是
Shure: This is...
Shure:  露西亚哈哈
Shure: Lucia, haha.
Lucia: 哦我们两个名字好像
Lucia: Oh, our names sound similar.
Alice: 你把他名写反了
Alice: You wrote his name backwards.
Katrina: 这
Katrina: This...
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Katrina: 刘雨萱哈哈哈
Katrina: Liu Yuxuan, hahaha.
Lucia:人家是  LYX哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake:差点差点像
Jake: Almost, almost looks like it.
Alice: 你再加一道就行
Alice: Just add another stroke.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 要对称
Shure: It needs to be symmetrical.
Katrina:  完了就是那个变异来XY染色体的
Katrina: Then it becomes XY chromosomes, like a mutation.
Shure:  对对对
Shure: Right, right.
Jake:变异
Jake: Mutation.
Shure:  好家伙这俩你都有
Shure: Wow, you've got both.
Shure:  是吗哈哈哈哈
Shure: Really? Hahaha.
Shure:  塔莎
Shure: Tasha.
Tasha: OK上我的道具拿出来
Tasha: OK, I'll get my props out.
Jake: 好上道具BGM
Jake: Alright, get the props and BGM ready.
Shure:  当当当当当当当
Shure: Da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Shure:  他的道具为什么在你的行李箱里
Shure: Why are his props in your suitcase?
Jake: 啊因为
Jake: Uh, because...
Shure: 又是带资进
Shure: Again, funded by himself?
Tasha: 不就这个
Tasha: Isn't it just this?
Tasha: 就这个啊
Tasha: Just this one?
Tasha: 你怎么没拆
Tasha: Why didn't you unpack it?
Tasha: 我去拿现成的吧
Tasha: I'll go get the ready-made one.
Tasha: 你把培养皿拿出来吧
Tasha: You take out the petri dish.
Shure:  培养皿
Shure: Petri dish.
Jake:培养皿
Jake: Petri dish.
Jake: 培养皿买了
Jake: Petri dish was bought.
Jake: 但是不一定到了
Jake: But it might not have arrived yet.
Jake: 不一定到哈
Jake: Might not have arrived.
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me check.
Katrina:  买了康乃馨
Katrina: Bought carnations.
Katrina:  这个叫叫叫
Katrina: This is called, called...
Katrina:  芍药康乃馨
Katrina: Peony carnations.
Katrina:  直播间买的
Katrina: Bought it in the live stream.
Lucia: 好好看呀
Lucia: Looks so nice.
Katrina:  直播间买
Katrina: Bought in the live stream.
Katrina:  顺丰秒送
Katrina: Delivered by SF Express instantly.
Katrina:  哎他昨天花瓶昨天也到了他没有
Katrina: Hey, the vase also arrived yesterday, but he didn't...
Jake: 对到了
Jake: Yes, it arrived.
Katrina:  这都是我们的快递
Katrina: These are all our packages.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 好像没有别的种类
Tasha: Seems like there are no other types.
Katrina:  可以装在这种里面
Katrina: Can be put in this kind.
Katrina:  我看一下
Katrina: Let me check.
Katrina:  弄出来特别漂亮
Katrina: Looks especially pretty when taken out.
Shure:  你这是香框
Shure: Is this a fragrance frame?
Katrina:  对就把花夹在里面
Katrina: Yes, just put the flowers in it.
Katrina:  还有一些叶子什么的可以摆在家里
Katrina: And some leaves or whatever, can be placed at home.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 有的
Shure: Got it.
Katrina:  这确实这怎么雾蒙蒙的
Katrina: Why is it so foggy?
Katrina:  他中间应该夹了一层东西
Katrina: There must be something sandwiched in the middle.
Jake: 被嫌弃了
Jake: It got rejected.
Jake: 我应该拆吗
Jake: Should I unpack it?
Tasha: 然后
Tasha: And then...
Tasha: 就是这是
Tasha: So this is...
Tasha: 自己设计的一些种子纸
Tasha: Some seed paper I designed myself
Tasha: 就是把种子放在这个纸里面
Tasha: It's basically putting seeds in this paper
Tasha: 这个纸是用废弃的咖啡渣
Tasha: This paper is made from discarded coffee grounds
Tasha: 呃一些纸
Tasha: Uh, some paper
Tasha: 然后做成那种纸浆
Tasha: And then making it into pulp
Tasha: 然后纸浆里面有那种乳
Tasha: And the pulp contains the seeds
Tasha: 种子都是用的太阳花种子
Tasha: The seeds are sunflower seeds
Tasha: 太阳花种子它比较容易发芽
Tasha: Sunflower seeds are easier to sprout
Tasha: 然后如果用培养皿水培的话
Tasha: And if you use a petri dish for hydroponics
Tasha: 大概5天左右就可以发芽
Tasha: It can sprout in about 5 days
Tasha: 然后做了一些种类的
Tasha: Then I made some different kinds
Tasha: 算世界地球日吗
Tasha: For Earth Day, right?
Jake: 那可地球了
Jake: Totally for Earth Day
Katrina:  都是你自己做的吗
Katrina: Did you make all of these yourself?
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, that's amazing
Tasha: 昂
Tasha: Yep
Katrina:  好厉害
Katrina: So impressive
Tasha: 然后做了5种
Tasha: And I made five kinds
Tasha: 地球的
Tasha: Earth-related ones
Tasha: 然后做了两种很简单的
Tasha: And two really simple ones
Katrina:  但是你是原创哎
Katrina: But they're your original designs
Jake: 有点强
Jake: Pretty strong
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah
Jake: 种子片
Jake: Seed paper
Jake: 种子片嗯
Jake: Seed paper, hmm
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah
Shure: 啊种子片
Shure: Ah, seed paper
Jake: 种子片嗯
Jake: Seed paper, hmm
Tasha: 嗯然后这样就比较环保
Tasha: Yeah, it's more environmentally friendly this way
Lucia: 真的很环保
Lucia: It's really eco-friendly
Katrina:  真的很环保
Katrina: It's really eco-friendly
Katrina:  而且还极具美感好吗
Katrina: And it's also very aesthetically pleasing
Katrina:  1234 好那
Katrina: 1234, okay then
Jake: 你自己设计的
Jake: Did you design it yourself?
Jake: 是画的图吗
Jake: Did you draw the pictures?
Alice:哦对我得去拿下我的东西
Alice: Oh, I need to go get my stuff
Tasha: 啊这很简单了
Tasha: Ah, it's really simple
Tasha: 就找一些logo
Tasha: Just find some logos
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha: 然后这个logo一找
Tasha: Then you just find this logo
Tasha: 写个字框个框就行了
Tasha: Just write a word and frame it.
Alice:哎呀不给你看
Alice: Oh no, I'm not showing you.
Jake: OK
Alice:天呐
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: So impressive.
Katrina:  种子卡片
Katrina: A seed card.
Katrina:  然后呢就是
Katrina: And then
Alice: 额买了一个拼图
Alice: Um, I bought a puzzle.
Alice: 是一个呃大底层是一个圆的
Alice: It's a big round base.
Alice: 然后它那个里面是这种的
Alice: And inside it, there are
Alice: 就是各种动物的那种
Alice: all kinds of animals.
Alice: 哦然后你看你能不能
Alice: Oh, and then you see if you can
Alice: 就是一个比较难的一个拼图
Alice: it's a relatively difficult puzzle.
Alice: 然后有很多种动物
Alice: And there are many kinds of animals.
Alice: 我想的就是呃你去尽力的往里面拼
Alice: What I think is, um, you try your best to fit it together.
Alice: 就是我觉得这个拼图就给人一种
Alice: I think this puzzle gives a feeling that
Alice: 我们在地球上
Alice: we are on Earth
Alice: 可以和谐共处的那个感觉
Alice: and can live harmoniously together.
Alice: 然后你不一定全都能拼上
Alice: And you might not be able to fit it all.
Alice: 但是因为这种不是那个严丝合缝
Alice: Because it's not perfectly seamless.
Alice: 不是特别完全严丝合缝
Alice: It's not very perfectly seamless.
Alice: 就是说你可以拼多一点
Alice: So you can fit more pieces,
Alice: 也可以拼少一点
Alice: or you can fit fewer pieces.
Alice: 然后我就想
Alice: And then I thought,
Alice: 呃可能就是一个小的游戏吧
Alice: um, maybe it's just a little game.
Jake: 你的头头发
Jake: Your hair
Jake: 呵呵呵要不
Jake: Haha, maybe
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah
Jake: 要不夹进去
Jake: Maybe clip it.
Katrina:  有没有夹子
Katrina: Do you have a clip?
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 今天买点发夹
Shure: Let's buy some hair clips today.
Alice: 然后就是
Alice: And then,
Alice: 我就想给参与者就是一个小奖品
Alice: I want to give the participants a small prize.
Alice: 就是一颗水仙种球
Alice: It's a daffodil bulb.
Alice: 因为这个水仙种球它好养
Alice: Because this daffodil bulb is easy to grow.
Alice: 就是呃
Alice: So, um
Alice: 在我的那种植物杀手朋友身上
Alice: Tried it on my plant-killer friend
Alice: 试验过了
Alice: It worked
Alice: 他都能养活的东西
Alice: If he can keep it alive
Alice: 然后这个花开出来也特别的好看
Alice: Then the flower that blooms is really beautiful
Alice: 然后还有清香的味道
Alice: And it has a lovely fragrance
Alice: 并且你看着他一天天长大
Alice: Plus, you get to watch it grow day by day
Alice: 你很有那种参与自然的感觉
Alice: It really gives you a sense of being part of nature
Alice: 对所以这就是我的想法
Alice: So that's my idea
Alice: 但是水仙球还没买
Alice: But I haven't bought the narcissus bulbs yet
Alice: 但是我有
Alice: But I know
Alice: 我知道有一家质量特别好的
Alice: I know a place that sells really good quality ones
Alice: 我养过的就是
Alice: The ones I grew were from there
Alice: 有需要他可以直接买过来
Alice: If you need, I can buy them directly
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Jake: Alright
Jake: 仙球
Jake: Narcissus bulbs
Shure:  活动内容现在有4个
Shure: We have 4 activities now
Shure:  到谁了
Shure: Whose turn is it?
Alice: 我接吧不是到我啊吗
Alice: I'll go, isn't it my turn?
Shure:  野生动物拼图
Shure: A wildlife puzzle
Katrina:  哎我还想让我第一天吃海底捞
Katrina: Oh, I still want to go to Haidilao on my first day
Katrina:  送了我一个种草莓的那个盆栽
Katrina: They gave me a strawberry planting kit
Katrina:  也可以种一下
Katrina: We can plant it too
Jake:海底捞
Jake: Haidilao
Tasha:那那个豌豆苗也可以种
Tasha: Then we can also plant pea shoots
Katrina:  海底捞就最近不是跟樱桃小丸子联名
Katrina: Haidilao recently partnered with Chibi Maruko-chan
Katrina:  点他那个东西他就送你那个盆栽
Katrina: If you order that, they give you the planting kit
Lucia: 哦这么好
Lucia: Oh, that's nice
Shure:  我们宿舍摆着呢
Shure: We have it in our dorm
Katrina:  我说他咋知道我要过来种东西
Katrina: I was wondering how they knew I wanted to plant something
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina:  我当时本来想买盆栽来着
Katrina: I was actually planning to buy a plant
Katrina:  想盆栽要一个月才能发芽
Katrina: But it takes a month for a plant to sprout
Jake: 走上海边种树去
Jake: Let's go plant trees by the sea
Shure:  然后到我了
Shure: Then it's my turn
Jake:到您了
Jake: Yes, it's your turn
Shure:  我的是一个
Shure: Mine is a
Shure:  一个类似于二手拍卖的
Shure: A kind of second-hand auction
Shure:  一个一个一个一个一个一个一个想法
Shure: An idea, idea, idea, idea, idea
Jake: OK
Shure:  我不知道大家平时会不会去一些什么
Shure: I don't know if you guys usually go to some places like...
Shure:  比如说小小小酒馆啊
Shure: For example, small bars...
Shure:  或者是咖啡店
Shure: Or coffee shops...
Shure:  就那种比较有烟火气的地方
Shure: You know, places with a bit of a cozy and lively atmosphere.
Shure:  然后之前那个
Shure: And before...
Shure:  北京有一个连锁的精酿啤酒
Shure: There was a craft beer chain in Beijing...
Shure:  叫跳海
Shure: Called Jumping Sea.
Katrina: 哦我知道在什刹海那是不是
Katrina: Oh, I know, it's in Shichahai, right?
Shure:  对什刹海
Shure: Yes, Shichahai.
Jake:应该是这个吧
Jake: It should be this one, right?
Shure:  然后
Shure: And...
Jake: 指的是这个吗
Jake: Are you talking about this one?
小薇;哪个
Tasha: Which one?
Shure:  其其他城市也有
Shure: It's also in other cities.
Jake:你刚刚让我拿这个吗
Jake: Did you just ask me to get this?
Shure:  什么市场也有
Shure: And in some markets too.
Shure:  然后他们前两天大榕寺开业的时候
Shure: And a few days ago, when they opened at Da Rong Temple...
Tasha: 我想让你帮忙帮忙把这个拿出来
Tasha: I wanted you to help take this out.
Jake:我结果拿多了
Jake: I ended up getting too much.
Shure:  他们搞了一个
Shure: They organized...
Shure:  就是这个拍卖的
Shure: Like an auction...
Jake:对不起
Jake: Sorry.
Shure:  一个一个一个形式吧
Shure: A kind of format.
Tasha: 这就一份吗
Tasha: Is this just one copy?
Shure:  然后就是
Shure: And then...
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jake:他们不知道
Jake: They don't know.
Tasha: 我说明信片就一份吗
Shure:  他们当时是你喝酒会给你一个币
Shure: At that time, if you drank, they would give you a token.
Jake:不知道
Jake: No idea.
Shure:  然后用这个币
Shure: And with that token...
Shure:  来买大家的一些任何的东西
Shure: You could buy anything from anyone.
Shure:  可以是一个是是一个诗集
Shure: It could be a poetry collection...
Shure:  可以是一个故事
Shure: It could be a story...
Shure:  然后也可以是一个
Shure: Or it could be a...
Shure:  就是真实存在的一个物品
Shure: A real physical item.
Shure:  然后就每人
Shure: And then everyone...
Shure:  就是那个每个物品都做一个小的PPT
Shure: So, for each item, we make a small PPT.
Shure:  然后展示出来
Shure: Then we present it.
Tasha: 哎呀还要做PPT啊
Tasha: Oh no, we have to make a PPT?
Shure:  然后然后然后哈哈哈哈
Shure: And then, and then, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 这是工作狂游戏吗
Lucia: Is this a workaholic game?
Shure: 啊不然后然
Shure: Uh, no, and then...
Shure:  后然后
Shure: After that...
Shure:  然后然后
Shure: And then...
Shure:  然后就是一个拍卖吧
Shure: Then there's an auction.
Shure:  然后我们可以怎么样呢
Shure: And we can...
Shure:  就是来的这些嘉宾
Shure: The guests who come...
Shure:  然后大家一人分享一个故事
Shure: Each person shares a story.
Shure:  或者是呃
Shure: Or, um...
Shure:  事故也好
Shure: An incident.
Shure:  故事也好
Shure: Or a story.
Shure:  然后来我们给评定
Shure: Then we evaluate it.
Shure:  觉得这个故事怎么样
Shure: See how the story is.
Jake: 值多少个币是吧
Jake: How many coins it's worth, right?
Shure:  对值多少个币
Shure: Yes, how many coins.
Shure:  然后给他
Shure: And then give it to them.
Shure:  然后这个币就什么
Shure: And then those coins...
Tasha: 一个故事换一根藤条的那种
Tasha: A story for a stick, that kind of thing.
Jake:昂
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  哦对
Shure: Oh, right.
Shure:  然后这个币就用来拍卖
Shure: Then those coins are used for the auction.
Shure:  接下来这些嘉宾带来的二手物品
Shure: For the second-hand items brought by the guests.
Shure:  以及是我们就是闲置的一些二手物品
Shure: And also for our own unused second-hand items.
Shure:  然后来进行这样的一个交换
Shure: And then we do an exchange.
Shure:  就是
Shure: It's...
Shure:  也是跟这个环保理念比较比较挂钩的
Shure: It's also closely related to the concept of environmental protection.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  行大概就是这个样子
Shure: Yeah, that's basically it.
Jake:妙啊
Jake: Brilliant.
Katrina:  就是讲故事
Katrina: So, we tell stories.
Katrina:  换了币然后就可以购买
Katrina: Earn coins and then we can buy...
Jake:购买一个
Jake: Buy something...
Katrina:  购买他们自己带来的闲置物品嘛
Katrina: Buy the items they brought themselves, right?
Shure:  每个人拍
Shure: Everyone auctions...
Shure:  拍卖就是比如说我
Shure: Auctions like, for example, I...
Shure:  我要卖一个什么东西
Shure: I want to sell something.
Shure:  然后我上来讲一下这个东西
Shure: Then I'll come up and talk about this item.
Shure:  然后我认为他的起拍价大概多少
Shure: And then I'll say what I think the starting bid should be.
Shure:  然后拍到这个钱
Shure: Then it will be auctioned off.
Shure:  是给到那个拍卖的那个人的
Shure: The money will go to the person who auctioned it.
Shure:  然后他也流通过去那个货币
Shure: And the currency will circulate.
Shure:  然后我拿着这些货币
Shure: Then I'll have some of this currency.
Shure:  我可以再去拍卖
Shure: I can go to another auction.
Shure:  你再去买别的
Shure: And buy other things.
Shure:  对剩下的
Shure: For the remaining items.
Alice: 反正就是换了一种交流的货币
Alice: So, it's basically just a different form of currency exchange.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina:  也构建了我们整个的经济体系
Katrina: It also builds our entire economic system.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  货币由头
Katrina: The origin of the currency.
Katrina: 我们都是这个市场的内容
Katrina: We are all part of this market.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Shure:  对可以把
Shure: Yes, you can add these too.
Shure:  这些也给加进来
Shure: These can also be included.
Jake:对都是商品
Jake: Yes, they are all commodities.
Katrina:  我们都是搞赚币的
Katrina: We are all in the currency business.
Alice:转币的 哈哈哈
Alice: In the currency business. Hahaha.
Lucia: 他是他是搞货币流通的
Lucia: He is in the currency circulation business.
Jake:昂
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 可以做一些手工艺品
Lucia: You can make some handicrafts.
Jake:对平台方
Jake: For the platform side.
Lucia: 用来用来拍卖
Lucia: To auction off.
Lucia: 对可以啊
Lucia: Yes, it can work.
Jake:  平台方和小店
Jake: The platform side and small shops.
Katrina:  就我们平台方做这个
Katrina: Just our platform side does this.
Jake: 也可以平台方和小店
Jake: The platform side and small shops can do it.
Jake: 小店家对
Jake: Small shops, right.
Jake:平台方京东
Jake: Platform side like JD.
Shure:  大概就是这样的形式
Shure: That's basically how it works.
Tasha: 这是我的商品
Tasha: This is my item.
Tasha: 我拍卖的
Tasha: I'm auctioning it off.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure:  还有什么想法吗
Shure: Any other thoughts?
Shure:  大家
Shure: Everyone.
Katrina:  我看看啊在那一天邀请他
Katrina: Let me see, invite him on that day.
Katrina:  们过来这是我们准备的一些嗯东东西
Katrina: They can come over, these are some things we prepared.
Katrina:  那怎么招待他们要不要搞一点什么
Katrina: How should we entertain them? Should we do something special?
Katrina:  就像我我我经常我们学校草坪发
Katrina: Like, I often hold events on our school's lawn.
Katrina:  他们会自己调酒
Katrina: They can make their own cocktails.
Katrina:  就自己自己
Katrina: Just by themselves.
Katrina:  人多的时候就有点像那种小party一样
Katrina: When there are a lot of people, it feels like a small party.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Shure:  我可以可以在外面给大家冲咖啡我那有有一套手冲的东西哈哈
Shure: I can make coffee for everyone outside, I have a set of pour-over tools, haha.
Katrina:  对就是可以请大家喝点东西
Katrina: Yes, we can serve drinks to everyone.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  笑的这么开心
Shure: Laughing so happily.
Jake: 突然开心的起来
Jake: Suddenly feeling happy.
Shure:  支持OK就表演c加a coffee and alcohol
Shure: Supporting OK, let's present C plus A, coffee and alcohol.
Shure:  嗯可以吧
Shure: Hmm, sounds good.
Katrina:  对那就是整个活动
Katrina: Yes, so the whole event,
Katrina:  那一天大概持续多长时间
Katrina: How long will it last on that day?
Jake: 一下午呗
Jake: An afternoon, I guess.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  一下午
Katrina: An afternoon.
Katrina:  嗯那就给他们提供一些饮品就够了吧
Katrina: Hmm, so just providing them with some drinks should be enough, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina:  先饮品然后我们就有点像
Katrina: First drinks, then we can have something like,
Katrina:  这这算市级部分
Katrina: This counts as a city-level part,
Katrina:  然后饮品部分也有了
Katrina: And then we have the drinks part,
Katrina:  那是不是还要什么节目啊您之前
Katrina: Do we need any programs? You mentioned before.
Jake: 嗯对可以
Jake: Hmm, yes, we can.
Jake: 嗯或者最后一天应该是从中午
Jake: Hmm, or on the last day, it should start from noon.
Jake: 中午管不管饭
Jake: Do we provide lunch?
Jake: 这个另说
Jake: That's another matter.
Jake: 也可以管也可以不管共多少个人
Jake: We can or cannot provide it, depending on the number of people.
Katrina:  好像
Katrina: Seems like,
Katrina:  不用管饭但是可以请他做一点点甜的
Katrina: We don't need to provide lunch, but we can offer some sweets.
Jake: 对对对下午茶
Jake: Yes, yes, afternoon tea.
Jake: 对嗯对那就是不用管饭
Jake: Yes, right, so no need to provide lunch.
Jake: 大家吃完饭过来
Jake: Everyone can come over after lunch.
Jake: 然后时间线我们捏一下
Jake: Then we can adjust the timeline.
Jake: 如果是下午开始两点比如说或者3点
Jake: If it starts in the afternoon, say 2 PM or 3 PM,
Jake: 3点一直干到晚上之类的
Jake: And goes on until the evening or so.
Katrina:  可以干到晚上但是天气怎么样
Katrina: We can go on until the evening, but how's the weather?
Jake: 这个就不知道了
Jake: I'm not sure about that.
Katrina:  我看会不会下雨不下雨的话如果像今天这种天的话
Katrina: I'll see if it rains. If it's like today...
Katrina:  弄到晚上还是挺漂亮的
Katrina: It'll still be pretty nice in the evening.
Jake: 对今天下午的话
Jake: Yeah, this afternoon...
Jake: 这个小院子应该也挺舒服的
Jake: This little yard should be quite comfortable.
Jake: 你还还可以烧烤
Jake: You can even have a barbecue.
Shure:  嗯是的
Shure: Yeah, that's right.
Jake: 买签了吗
Jake: Did you buy the skewers?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  还没呢我今天一起购入
Shure: Not yet, I'll get them today.
Jake: 好的还要买碳的对吧
Jake: Alright, and we need to buy charcoal too, right?
Shure:  签碳肉这些其实就是外卖都有其实可以当日达的
Shure: Skewers, charcoal, meat, all these can be delivered on the same day.
Jake:昂昂   行行
Jake: Yeah, okay, sounds good.
Katrina:  21号
Katrina: The 21st.
Shure:  大家平时厨艺如何
Shure: How's everyone's cooking skills?
Shure:  就是会使用刀吗
Shure: Can you handle a knife?
Jake: 哈哈哈什么叫会使用
Jake: Hahaha, what do you mean by handle?
Katrina: 我我还行
Katrina: I'm alright.
Shure:  能切个肉什么的吗
Shure: Can you cut meat?
Jake: 能切都能切吧
Jake: We can all cut meat, right?
Jake: 都能切各位都能切了
Jake: Everyone can cut it, no problem.
Shure: OK 有大家这句话我就放心了
Shure: Okay, hearing that puts my mind at ease.
Jake: 因因为你不切
Jake: Because you won't be cutting.
Lucia: 稍微冷藏一下
Lucia: Slightly chill it.
Lucia: 然后拿出来稍微放一会的时候好切
Lucia: Then let it sit a bit before cutting, it's easier that way.
Lucia: 嗯如果是软的肉我不是很会切
Lucia: If the meat is soft, I'm not good at cutting it.
Lucia: 就已经化好的那种
Lucia: When it's already thawed.
Shure: 明白行
Shure: Got it, alright.
Jake: 行可以烤是吧
Jake: Okay, we can grill it, right?
Shure:  可以烤
Shure: We can grill it.
Jake:长春烤串
Jake: Changchun skewers.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina:  其实调酒好像就是买买一点那种啤酒
Katrina: Actually, for cocktails, you just need to buy some beer.
Katrina:  对然后搞一点冰块
Katrina: Yeah, and get some ice.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Shure:  冰块的话
Shure: About the ice...
Katrina:  哎我现在前面我们走两步
Katrina: Hey, there's a café a few steps ahead.
Katrina:  不是有个咖啡厅
Katrina: Should we ask them for some ice?
Katrina:  能不能问他们借点冰块
Katrina: So we don't have to buy an ice machine.
Katrina:  就不用自己买制冰机了
Katrina: It saves us the trouble.
Katrina:  可以请问他们花钱买点冰块
Katrina: Can we ask them to buy some ice?
Katrina:  那边有咖啡厅吗
Katrina: Is there a café over there?
Katrina:  对啊昨天停车那位置
Katrina: Yeah, the spot where we parked yesterday.
Lucia: 如果我们要求不那么高的话
Lucia: If our requirements aren't too high,
Lucia: 就是买一个冰膜然后自己冻一下
Lucia: we can just buy an ice mold and freeze it ourselves.
Lucia: 也可以啊
Lucia: That works too.
Lucia: 只不过就是冻出来可能没有
Lucia: It's just that the ice might not be as
Lucia: 咖啡厅透明
Lucia: clear as the café's.
Katrina:  我们有冰箱
Katrina: We have a fridge.
Katrina:  就买个那个模具倒点水
Katrina: Just buy the mold and pour some water in.
Katrina:  前天晚上冻一下
Katrina: Freeze it overnight.
Alice: 用蒸馏水就行
Alice: Just use distilled water.
Alice: 就煮过煮沸的水
Alice: Boiled water works too.
Jake:嗯蒸馏水
Jake: Hmm, distilled water.
Shure:  还行呵呵呵
Shure: Not bad, haha.
Shure:  我们到底是在搞什么
Shure: What are we even doing?
Shure:  搞实验了是吗
Shure: Are we doing an experiment or what?
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Katrina:  那他整整体的时间流程呢
Katrina: So what's the overall schedule then?
Jake: 比如说我们从入场3点3点开始吧
Jake: For example, we start at 3 PM, right?
Katrina:  几点到几点干什么
Katrina: What do we do from what time to what time?
Katrina: From what time to what time?
Katrina:  因为就5个人
Katrina: Because there are only five of us.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Katrina:  这个有点像那种市集
Katrina: This feels like a market.
Katrina:  但是那种市集一般都是比较大
Katrina: But those markets are usually bigger.
Katrina:  然后大家随意逛
Katrina: People just wander around.
Katrina:  但是我们这个地方比较小
Katrina: But our place is smaller.
Katrina:  那你肯定要规定一定的时间干什么
Katrina: So we need to set specific times for activities.
Katrina:  一定的时间干什么
Katrina: Specific times for activities.
Katrina:  要不然容易他们一下就看完了
Katrina: Otherwise, they'll finish everything too quickly.
Jake: 对你的拍卖可以占一点时间
Jake: Your auction can take up some time.
Jake: 看占多长时间
Jake: See how long it takes.
Jake: 然后
Jake: Then...
Jake: 唉
Jake: Sigh.
Jake: 就这些准备都是我们这几天准备对吧
Jake: All these preparations are what we've been working on these past few days, right?
Jake: 然后别的耗时间的短剧
Jake: Then other time-consuming short activities...
Jake: 跳舞吗哈哈哈
Jake: Dancing? Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈我一个人跳吗
Lucia: Haha, am I dancing alone?
Jake: 以前也对  以前也可以跳
Jake: We used to do it before, we can do it again.
Katrina:  可以拍个稍微简单点的
Katrina: Can we shoot something a bit simpler?
Jake:帅也可以跳
Jake: Choiszt can dance too.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Katrina: 你也可以跳吗
Katrina: Can you dance too?
Lucia: 短片如果有现成的剧本的话
Lucia: If we have a script for a short film...
Lucia: 我们可以拍一个哈哈哈
Lucia: We can shoot one, haha.
Shure:  演其实有有点小尬
Shure: Acting is actually a bit awkward.
Katrina:  嗯不如跳舞
Katrina: Hmm, dancing is better.
Katrina:  因为那个音乐放上了
Katrina: Because once the music starts...
Jake:不如跳舞
Jake: Let's dance instead.
Lucia: 不如跳舞
Lucia: Let's dance instead.
Alice: 谈恋爱不如跳舞
Alice: Dancing is better than dating.
Shure:  不如跳舞
Shure: Let's dance instead.
Shure:  捋一下时间线吧
Shure: Let's go over the timeline.
Lucia: 可是跳舞的话戴眼镜会掉耶
Lucia: But if we dance, my glasses might fall off.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 还戴眼镜那时候
Shure: Wearing glasses at that time?
Shure:  那我们可以挑点简单的
Shure: We can choose something simpler.
Shure:  蘑菇蘑菇哎
Shure: Mushrooms, mushrooms, hey!
Lucia: 我们可以跳抖音上的那种
Lucia: We can dance to something from TikTok.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  这个听我说
Shure: Listen to me.
Shure:  谢谢你对对对
Shure: Thank you, yes, yes.
Lucia: 对对对抖音上就大家都可以一起挑
Lucia: Yes, on TikTok everyone can join in.
Lucia: 就是排的时间也会短一些对吧
Lucia: It also takes less time to plan, right?
Lucia: 也没有什么比较大的动作
Lucia: And there aren't any big moves.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 戴眼镜也不影响
Lucia: Glasses won't get in the way.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure:  捋下时间线
Shure: Let's go over the timeline.
Tasha: 可拍满100个硬币
Tasha: We can shoot 100 coins.
Tasha: 哈哈哈啊
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:啊   买
Jake: Ah, buy them.
小薇;啊没事
Tasha: Ah, it's okay.
Tasha: 我只是觉得应该买实体硬币
Tasha: I just think we should buy real coins.
Jake:哦 可以买 采购
Jake: Oh, we can buy them, procurement.
Katrina:  哦哦不对
Katrina: Oh, no, wait.
Katrina:  拍卖之前首先要他们讲故事
Katrina: Before the auction, they need to tell a story.
Katrina:  才能获得那个币
Katrina: Only then can they get the coins.
Jake: 对对对就是这个时间
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, it's this time.
Jake: 可能就得放一个半小时了对
Jake: It might take about an hour and a half.
Jake: 就就你们昨天的那个活动
Jake: Just like your event yesterday.
Jake: 也也两个小时了
Jake: It was also two hours.
Shure: 也不用讲那么长
Shure: No need to make it that long.
Shure:  就讲一个小故事
Shure: Just tell a short story.
Shure:  一个每个人5分钟那种大概
Shure: Like, each person gets 5 minutes or so.
Jake:哦  可以啊
Jake: Oh, that works.
Shure:  或者时间成本控制不好的话
Shure: Or if we can't control the time cost well...
Shure:  就以其他形式获得币
Shure: We can gain the coins in other ways.
Shure:  但是这个活动的核心是那个拍卖过程
Shure: But the core of this event is the auction process.
Shure:  但是这个货币怎么获得
Shure: As for how to earn the coins...
Shure:  可以再进一步上去
Shure: We can refine that further.
Jake: 嗯嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Shure:  对拍卖过程这个是要保留的
Shure: Yes, we need to keep the auction process.
Shure:  大概像9个人的话每个人5分钟
Shure: For about 9 people, each person gets 5 minutes.
Shure:  5945一个小时吧
Shure: 5945, that's an hour.
Shure:  就按一个小时算的
Shure: We can just consider it as an hour.
Lucia: 路上给大家发一些币
Lucia: Hand out some coins on the way.
Lucia: 然后通过摇骰子让大家玩一会
Lucia: And let everyone play by rolling dice.
Katrina: 啊可以设置一些游戏
Katrina: Ah, we can set up some games.
Jake:嗯对对对
Jake: Mm, yeah, yeah.
Jake: 哈哈哈整点游戏可以
Jake: Hahaha, some games would be fine.
Shure:  我们门门口再来一个
Shure: Let's have one at the entrance.
Lucia: 哈哈哈没有没有开个玩笑
Lucia: Hahaha, no, just kidding.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 可以可以可以
Lucia: Okay, okay, okay.
Lucia: 确实啊
Lucia: Seriously.
Lucia: 这个听起来有点
Lucia: This sounds a bit...
Lucia: 哈哈哈一会发鸡蛋一会摇骰子
Lucia: Hahaha, handing out eggs and rolling dice.
Jake:然后
Jake: Then...
Jake: 哈哈哈据点是吧
Jake: Hahaha, it's like a stronghold.
Shure:  一锅端了小心这
Shure: Be careful, we might get busted.
Tasha: 进来玩玩嘛进来就可以获得10个币
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Katrina:  但是一一进来就让
Katrina: But once they come in...
Katrina:  就是刚开始肯定要获得货币
Katrina: At first, they definitely need to earn some currency.
Katrina:  但是你获得货币
Katrina: But to earn currency...
Katrina:  是要他们通过讲故事的方式
Katrina: They need to do it by telling stories.
Katrina:  但是他们一进来可能还没那么熟
Katrina: But when they first come in, they might not be that familiar.
Katrina:  就要让他们在众人面前讲故事干什么
Katrina: And we expect them to tell stories in front of everyone?
Katrina:  那就自我介绍
Katrina: How about self-introductions?
Tasha: 会冷场可以获得一个币啊
Tasha: It might be awkward, but they can earn a coin!
Jake:昂
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 自我介绍可以获得
Lucia: Self-introductions can earn...
Katrina:  对啊自我介绍可以获得
Katrina: Yeah, self-introductions can earn...
Jake:自我介绍获得或者
Jake: Earn through self-introductions or...
Alice: 第一个给5个
Alice: The first one gets five.
Alice: 第二个给仨
Alice: The second one gets three.
Katrina:  奖惩机制
Katrina: Reward and punishment system.
Jake: 或者我们其实在这个屋子里面
Jake: Or we could actually hide things in this room.
Jake: 可以藏点东西
Jake: And then, um...
Jake: 然后啊
Jake: Like...
Lucia: 像复活节的那种寻彩蛋游戏一样
Lucia: Like an Easter egg hunt kind of game?
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Jake: 藏点币
Jake: Hide some coins.
Shure:  藏币也行
Shure: Hiding coins works too.
Katrina:  就是刚开始自我介绍获得币
Katrina: So, at first, earn coins through self-introductions.
Katrina:  然后玩玩点小游戏赢赢了的币
Katrina: Then play some mini-games to win more coins.
Shure:  对就比如说一些问答什么的
Shure: Yeah, like some quiz or something.
Shure:  野生动物拼图那个
Shure: Like the wildlife puzzle one.
Lucia: 哎问答的话反正是世界地球日
Lucia: Yeah, since it's Earth Day anyway.
Lucia: 对可以
Lucia: Yeah, that's good.
Lucia: 知识问答知识问答
Lucia: Knowledge quizzes, knowledge quizzes.
Shure:  知识问答得币
Shure: Earn coins through knowledge quizzes.
Shure:  对对对好
Shure: Yeah, exactly, great.
Shure:  我想起来了
Shure: I remember now.
Tasha: 好世界地球日是哪一天
Tasha: Alright, when is Earth Day?
Katrina: 先要把那个
Katrina: First, we need to...
Lucia: 二十几来着
Lucia: It's on the twenty-something.
Katrina: 先要把这个钱给让他们得到
Katrina: First, we need to let them earn that money.
Jake:二十二我把我把二十一来搞
Jake: Twenty-second. I'll go with the twenty-first.
Katrina:  然后再开始推销
Katrina: Then we start promoting...
Jake:因为是星期天
Jake: Because it's a Sunday.
Katrina:  推销我们的产品
Katrina: Promoting our products.